the hardest things to do with technology
another they're impossible but the
hardest thing to do technology have to
do with if you like molten sensory
perception challenges those Rises and
now we've made progress on those by the
way so you know humanoid robots have
made huge progress a bit to sense
environments made huge progress but
we've not made anywhere near as much
progress on that as we've made in the
more reasoning thinking tasks the
knowledge work and the reason why those
two differences are interesting is that
so I'll stay with the the called the
physical sensory perception end of that
spectrum you end up still needed you
actually build machines that actually
cost money that have arms and legs and
whatever physical things that will move
things around it's also the place where
there's there'll be an abundance of
human labor available and so the
combination of the costs not so much
progress and the availability of human
labor will probably mean that we'll see
less automation happen there because
there's always going to be an
alternative whereas if you go to the
other end of the spectrum where it's
mostly thinking work the algorithm that
does the medical diagnosis or pattern
recognition or image recognition is
essentially an algorithm there's no
moving parts so to speak
so the economists that are very very low
and by the way we've made more progress
there in the last five years and we've
made in the last 50 with machine
learning and deep learning and by the
way that's where the labor and the
skills are in short supply so when you
put the technology and the labor
economics that go with it which is a
shortage you'll likely to see more of it
actually being applied there if you look
at the sector like manufacturing for
example you know a pick a period 2000
2008 2000 ages because that was the
start of the recession in that period
much of the conversation we had about
you know the five point eight million
jobs we lost in in manufacturing was
always a conversation about offshoring
now when we look back and various
economists have different estimates of
this we have our
but for the most part roughly about 20%
of the jobs lost in that period were in
fact due to offshoring the rest was a
combination of Technology driven
automation as well as shortfalls in
demand at some level and you've got
economies like the United States where
something like you know 60% of our GDP
growth comes from household and you know
and consumer consumption and spending
it's going to be important for people to
be able to consume and spend to drive
GDP so people aren't earning anything
because they're not working whatever the
case may be what happens to that so I
think this question of automation is
actually a bigger deal I think we got
distracted a little bit of the
offshoring question of course that's
that's real but the bigger question is
what happens to work